foreign
[Music]
Pirates of the Caribbean 6 is coming
from the creator of The Last of Us One
Piece is surprising everyone and there's
finally info on the release of Arcane
season 2. plus there are new details on
Toy Story 5 a number of Marvel
postponements and a movie adaptation of
a very special video game
two infinity and beyond Buzz Lightyear
couldn't describe his own Toy Story film
series any better after the huge success
of part 4 the franchise is now set to
get a fifth installment in which a true
fan favorite could return Disney's Toy
Story Series has been a tremendous hit
Toy Story 4 which was actually intended
to conclude the film series grossed over
1 billion dollars globally and was also
given the Academy Award for best
animated feature of course the company
is not going to pass up the opportunity
to produce another part of the series
which was announced earlier in 2023
according to the Disney Insider there
are no details about the storyline yet
but the sequel is expected to be quite
surprising as stated by The Toy Story
producers there will be many things to
see that have not yet been featured in
the previous films the cast around Tom
Hanks and Tim Allen will dub The
Familiar characters once again only Mr
and Mrs Potato Head are to receive new
dubbing voices since the former actors
have since passed away allegedly they
want to use AI generated voices moreover
Andy is to return as an adult and play a
key role together with his family this
should confirm existing fan theories
that already suspected Andy's comeback
if you're interested in these theories
feel free to check out our Toy Story 5
movie preview currently Toy Story 5 is
expected to hit theaters in June 2025
but the release date may change
eventually due to the ongoing Raiders
and actor strike in the United States
we are heading back to piltover three
years after the success of the League of
Legends adaptation Arcane the series is
set to return next year with a second
season Arcane proved to be an absolute
surprise hit for Netflix in 2021 and
thrilled not just fans of the original
with a fantastic look due to the adult
style and the approach to topics such as
mental health the series was also able
to win over critics four Emmy awards
were the result since then fans have
been eagerly awaiting for a second
season which unfortunately is still some
time away it has now been announced that
the sequel will be released in the
winter of next year Riot games CEO
Niccolo Laurent gave two reasons why
season two was not ready yet for one
they wanted to ensure a high level of
quality so they didn't want to rush on
the other hand they didn't know if
season one would be a success and so
they were late in starting the
production of the sequel there's no
concrete information about the plot of
season 2 so far but it will probably
follow on from the end of season 1 which
ended with a big cliffhanger
finally the sales are being set again
six years after Pirates of the Caribbean
5 part 6 will finally follow and take us
back to the world of the pirates for the
new movie Disney was able to hire Craig
Mason as a screenwriter who was already
in charge of the series adaptation of
The Last of Us after Pirates of the
Caribbean 5 dead men tell no Tales the
pirate franchise went surprisingly quiet
granted the fifth installment gave
plenty of reason for that with worldwide
box office earnings of around 800
million dollars the film was indeed
successful but fell short of fans
expectations critics weren't too
impressed either punishing the film with
an overall score of 39 out of 100 on
Metascore nevertheless fans hoped that
the franchise could return to its Old
Glory at some point possibly with the
Pirates of the Caribbean 6. Disney also
seems to show further interest in the
film series and has been working on a
possible sequel for years initially a
spin-off with Margot Robbie was to
follow but this has been put on ice for
the time being Now The Last of Us author
Craig Mason and now announced in an
interview with the LA Times that he had
already written a story for another film
he presented it to Disney and thought it
might be a little too strange for the
company Disney however was thrilled and
gave the green light as a result Mason
was also responsible for the hit series
Chernobyl will write the final
screenplay for Pirates of the Caribbean
6 together with Ted Elliott the latter
already wrote Parts one to four whether
the new movie will be a continuation of
the Johnny Depp series or a spin-off
remains unclear it is also unknown
whether Johnny Depp Orlando Bloom and
Kyra Knightley will reprise their iconic
roles since the series continues to
enjoy great popularity part 6 should
also be eagerly anticipated and
hopefully bring new impedis to the
pirate genre
Full Speed Ahead to success with the
live-action adaptation of the popular
anime one piece Netflix May well have
pulled off one of the year's biggest
surprises the series entered the Netflix
charts at the top spot even overtaking
the previous records of stranger things
and Wednesday with the live action
adaptations of Death Note and Cowboy
Bebop Netflix has previously attempted
to adapt well-known anime but to no
avail thus there was a lot of skepticism
among fans when the streaming service
announced an adaptation of the popular
pirate Adventure one piece as of August
31st however these fears have vanished
Into Thin Air as the series is making
viewers excited Luffy and his friends
have a high average rating of 83 points
on Rotten Tomatoes and are currently
ranked number one on Netflix in more
than 84 countries something that no
Series has ever achieved before now of
course there's the question of when One
Piece season 2 will follow due to the
tremendous response a continuation of
the series is very likely but might
still be a long time coming Hollywood is
currently still on strike and the budget
may be a factor as well the adaptation
is considered one of the most expensive
series ever and at 18 million dollars
per episode it's even outshining Game of
Thrones either way one piece should
ensure that people are more at ease when
it comes to Future anime adaptations
avatar The Last Airbender is to get a
new series next year while Pokemon and
my hero Academia are also on the
streaming giant schedule
things are changing at Marvel the show
calendar for the remaining months of
2023 has been completely scrapped and is
likely to disappoint a lot of people the
second season of Loki will be the only
live action series to be released this
year Marvel's secret invasion was a huge
flaw leaving critics and fans
disappointed a mere 994 thousand viewers
opted to watch the first episode of the
series about Nick Fury and the Scrolls
making it the second worst debut ever
for a Marvel series after Miss Marvel in
terms of quality things are looking
Bleak as well the finale barely achieved
a score of 10 on Rotten Tomatoes and
thus fell short of expectations now
Marvel seems to have taken the criticism
to heart and is pushing back several
projects to 2024. as The Hollywood
Reporter points out there are possibly
two reasons for this decision first some
projects are still in production and are
therefore affected by the actors and
writer strike second Marvel will now
also react to the negative feedback on
their previous Productions as such
Studio announced that future projects
will be released at a greater interval
in order to make each series an event
this has now resulted in seven
productions being postponed until next
year and some even indefinitely echo
which is a spin-off to the Hawkeye
series and is said to have a grittier
and more grounded tone is set to kick
off in January of 2024. next up is an
animated Return of the X-Men in X-Men 97
which was meant to be a sequel to the
1990 Classic series and is now slated to
Premiere in Spring of 2024. likewise we
will have to wait a little while longer
for Catherine Han as AG at the Harkness
the one division spin-off Agatha dark
hole Diaries will not be out until fall
of 2024. ironheart is a series based
around the inventor Riri Williams who
was already introduced in Black Panther
wakanda forever and was supposed to
Premiere this fall however due to the
strike the production is on hold and so
the release has been indefinitely
postponed the rescheduling of Daredevil
born again is also expected to result in
disappointment for fans after all a
return of Charlie Cox's Matt Murdock in
the MCU was regarded as highly
anticipated Wonder Man played by Yaya
Abdul Mateen II is also a long time
coming nevertheless we won't have to do
without the MCU altogether this year the
second season of Loki will still
premiere on October 6 2023 and what if
season 2 will also be available around
Christmas
it might become the movie for cat lovers
in 2022 the game straight excited
countless gamers in it you control the
cat through a world populated by robots
now the adventure is to be made into a
film Annapurna animations Netflix film
nimona was a big success especially
among the queer Community now the studio
is working with blue 12 on a movie
adaptation of the Indie hit stray in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
Robert braid head of Annapurna animation
describe the planned animation film as a
buddy comedy about a cat and a robot the
game he said is about what makes us
human even though it's a comedy that
doesn't feature humans this purely
animal perspective is what has
contributed to the popularity of the
game they also want to try to transfer
the emotional component of the game into
the movie and at the same time stay as
close as possible to the original it
remains to be seen when we will be able
to watch the adventure after all the
movie is at the beginning of its
production and will likely take some
time nevertheless we are already very
excited about the adventure with
adorable cat
this concludes the news for today which
of the mentioned movies and series are
you looking forward to the most let us
know in the comments and if you enjoyed
this video please hit the thumbs up for
more content check out our new movie
preview for Beetlejuice 2. if you
haven't already thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you